pftot on yahoo sports peter king mike
floria with all the big stories
happening in the national football
league and look the 2018 nfl mvp got his
payoff a year later with the super bowl
mvp lamar jackson the 2019 nfl mvp would
like that same outcome this year it's
always better to be the super bowl mvp
than the regular season mvp
can lamar jackson find that higher level
that will carry the ravens just beyond a
great regular season and into a great
postseason as well peter
yeah i mean mike i i wrote my column
this week that uh i am not ready to
uh just because lamar jackson has had
two lousy playoff games two consecutive
years at home
uh
and i'm just not ready to say that oh he
can't be a great january february
quarterback at all
i think he makes a comeback this year
and he makes a comeback in part because
as good as his running game was last
year was the best running game in
football i think they're going to be
even a notch better this year after
adding jk dobbins
and i think that the offense is going to
be less on his shoulder so that let's
just say
you get behind by 10 in the second
quarter of a playoff game okay
now
they're not gonna feel greg roman the
offensive coordinator is not gonna feel
that okay we're gonna we're throwing 90
of the time the rest of the day just
stay with what got you there and i think
what's going to get them there is not
only the legs and the electric arm of
lamar jackson but i think jk dobbins and
mark ingram by the end of this year with
all due respect to the other great
running tan tandems in football
i think this one is going to be the best
i think one of the real tests for the
ravens this year it's something that
bill belichick has perfected and i think
it's going to be a huge challenge for
john harbaugh
get your team to forget completely about
what happened last year forget that you
were 14 and 2. forget that you won 12
games in a row forget that you were the
number one seed because if they have any
difficulty out of the gates that's going
to haunt them that's going to loom
that's going to hover and they've got to
forget about it they've got to treat
this like a new season ignore what they
did last year and try to build and build
and build and then when they get to
january they have to forget those other
two playoff games how it felt they need
to remember how it felt to lose but you
know peter this is starting to remind me
of the bengals where every time the
bengals would get back to the playoffs
the narrative gets stronger the
questions become more frequent and the
frustration can build they've got to get
this past them they've got to get to
january and win a playoff game or who
knows how many years it almost is like a
barry bonds thing for lamar jackson
where every year it gets worse and worse
and the pressure gets greater and
greater and they this year they
desperately need to win in the
postseason
no question about it it's it renders
whatever you do in the regular season
meaningless if you lose if the ravens
lose their first playoff game this year
i don't care if they go 16-0 in the
regular season renders it meaningless
and in to my way of thinking mike the
most important thing for them to
remember this year
is you know don't put everything on
lamar jackson okay you don't need to you
don't have to your defense is going to
be better kalaeus campbell makes that
front
better
it just does the secondary is really
good this
if these guys have gotten to davey and
clowny it would have been crazy
but but this is a team right now that
doesn't have to have a bunch of 380 yard
passing days from the quarterback to win
he just has to be
a cog in the wheel maybe the best cog in
the wheel but he's got to be a cog in
the wheel don't go putting everything on
this guy's shoulders you don't have to
and this is the best news for teams like
the ravens teams like the texans teams
like the chiefs and the cardinals some
of the best young quarterbacks in the
nfl don't have much experience as they
get more experience as they see more
defenses as they run through more plays
they're going to get better and better
and that's what the ravens have to look
forward to with lamar jackson he's just
getting started we're getting finished
though we'll have pft ot on yahoo videos
for you all season long he's better king
i'm mike florio and we'll see you here
next time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports